even during his lifetime there was never
any doubt that the first line in every
obituary for Bob Barker would be about
his role as host of The Price is Right
but that's not what Barker himself
really wanted to be remembered for in
2007 he spoke with interviewer Terry
Morrow of the Knoxville News Sentinel
about his legacy saying I think that it
would be nice if people remembered me as
a guy who loved all living things and
did as much as he could to make ours a
better world for animals and also did
quite a few television shows well rest
easy Bob because you just about got your
wish while his role as host of Price is
Right did indeed top his memorials
following his passing in August of 2023
it was his work fighting for animal
rights that was often mentioned right up
there with it health control the pet
population have your pets spayed or
neutered